bonsoir bienvenue dans audition publique
c'est d'autres rendez vous du lundi en
direct sur lcp public sénat le figaro
une heure de débat et de confrontation
avec notre invité ce soir fabien roussel
bonsoir le soir vous êtes secrétaire
nationale du parti communiste français
le 49-3 donc été déclenchée par le
premier ministre samedi les oppositions
dont parti communiste qui avaient déposé
des dizaines de milliers d'amendements
se voit couper l'herbe sous le pied mais
vous répliqué avec une motion de censure
on va y revenir tout à l'heure on va
également parlé des menaces que fait
peser l'épidémie connor coronavirus
notamment et puis dans quelques instants
mais qu'on sort des chaînes
parlementaires nous rejoindront pour
vous poser des questions
ainsi qu'une députée de la république en
marche et à sénateur apparenté les
républicains là aussi pour débattre avec
vous et puis yves thréard du figaro qui
viendra vous poser ces questions à la
fin de cette émission plus celle que les
téléspectateurs peuvent nous faire
parvenir avec le hashtag audition
publique ou sur lefigaro.fr
première question demain des
manifestations partout en france c'est
l'appel de la cgt différents syndicats
pour protester contre le déclenchement
du 49-3 par le gouvernement qui stoppe
tous les débats sur la réforme des
retraites à l'assemblée nationale vous
serez dans la rue vous soutenez ce
mouvement j'imagine je serai à
l'assemblée nationale et dans la rue
avec eux comme je lé fais d'ailleurs
depuis plus de deux mois et demi oui ces
mobilisations ce sera un test pour voir
si ça retard ou pas oh je sais pas si
c'est un test si on peut le voir comme
ça en jeu le sens plutôt comme une
réaction d'émotion et de colère de la
part de ceux qui suivaient quand même
les débats à l'assemblée nationale
depuis des mois nous demandons le
retrait de ce texte le gouvernement
n'entend rien ils passent en force le
dépose à l'assemblée nationale malgré
tout nous demandons un référendum par
une motion référendaire
on s'en moque le débat aura lieu quand
même et puis là les amendements des fils
et ça défile le débat avait lieu
nous essayons nous par nos amendements
de faire éclater la vérité de savoir
quel est l'âge déquilibre à partir de
quel âge n décote ou pas etc etc c'est
ce que vous essaierez est ce que vous
espérez une forte mobilisation pour vous
soutenir
finalement pour soutenir votre travail
d'opposant à l'assemblée nationale est
ce que vous
spiric la rue ce maïs beaucoup de jeu ma
crainte c'est que aujourd'hui la
république sorte abîmée de cet épisode
sincèrement jamais on a vu un
gouvernement utiliser le 49-3 dans une
telle situation
ça a déjà été utilisé le 49-3 mais quand
un gouvernement était en difficulté
parce que sa majorité était divisée
on a déjà utilisé pas nous mais des
gouvernements le 49-3 quand il fallait
aller vite parce qu'il y avait une
urgence par exemple à une urgence
sanitaire peut justifier de 49,3 sur des
mesures d'urgence pour l'hôpital public
pourrait se justifier mais là une
utiliser le 49-3 pour avec brutalité
faire passer en force un texte de loi
est allé vite
nous n'avons jamais vu ça reviendra donc
ma question à qui les augures et une
forte mobilisation ce que que ça relais
j'allais dire votre position sur les
bandes moyens il faut la mobilisation la
plus forte des salariés du monde du
travail
ce que je souhaite le plus ardemment
c'est que l'on sorte de cette situation
par le haut c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons proposé nous
proposons encore je le redis ce soir que
le gouvernement fasse ce choix d'un
référendum que l'on prenne le temps de
l'organiser en l'espace d'un mois de
deux mois avec oui ou non à cette
réforme des retraites par points
et cela le peuple et le dernier mot et
que l'on passe à autre chose
mais là que l'on que l'on sorte de cette
crise démocratique qui va véritablement
abîmer nos institutions notre république
on va passer aux premiers moments de
cette émission en accueillant mes
consoeurs des chaînes parlementaires
soit rapprochée de sécurité s'était pas
lancé brigitte parce qu'on va évidemment
aller sur la ou les motions de censure
devrions-nous dire oui je précise juste
une chose c'est que l'homme 49 ans a été
utilisé en cas d'obstruction sous
edouard balladur et sous jean-pierre
raffarin donc c'est pas forcément quand
on n'a pas de majorité ou une majorité
instable ma question portait sur vous
allez défendre demain une motion de
censure dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale
quel sera exactement le contenu de ce
texte c'est un texte qui demande tout
simplement à respecter les droits du
parlement et le débat démocratique qui
s'instaurait au sein de l'hémicycle
conflit avec 41 mille amendements au
départ quand le débat a été interrompue
brutalement par le premier ministre à
l'issue d'un conseil des ministres qui
étaient consacrées au courant d'un virus
et soudée moi du peu quand même
nous en étions à 29 mille cinq cents
amendements
donc on avait avancé quand même il y
avait plus de 11000 amendement qui avait
été discutée il en restait 29 me nous
aurions pu continuer mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya d'étrange à ce que ce que nous
dénonçons c'est la forme et le fond la
forme parce que on n'a pas le droit
d'utiliser le 49-3 sur un texte aussi
important fondamentale qui engagent
notre pays ou que ça pour les 150 ans de
la chaîne année sur deux mains oui
et sur le fond parce que nous continuons
de dire qu'une majorité de nos
concitoyens rejette cette réforme et que
le gouvernement la majorité aurait la
sagesse ou de le retirer ou d'organiser
le référendum comme jamais un compromis
entre les socialistes les insoumis et
vous ce texte finalement est-ce que vous
avez dû faire des concessions pour
rallier ces noms parce qu' est-ce qu'il
ya par exemple le départ à la retraite à
60 ans et si nous sommes est ce qui
apparaît en le départ le monde parce que
on n'est pas là dessus c'est pas l'objet
de la motion de censure nous communistes
nous avons nous communistes défaut d des
amendements pour demander le
rétablissement de la retraite à 60 ans
et des amendements pour montrer comment
il était possible de financer
c'est cette réforme des retraites il ya
des accords avec les socialistes
ce oui là dessus
vont pas les mêmes propositions donc ce
n'est pas dans la motion de censure non
c'est pas ça je n'essaie pas l'objet de
la motion de censure c'est pas de
présenter le programme du parti
communiste français
non puisque c'est d'eux s'est allié avec
les a soumis oui il n'y a pas eu de mal
à nous trois à écrire le sens de cette
motion de censure dont nous parlons
depuis plusieurs semaines donc il n'y a
pas eu de difficultés là dessus nous
sommes d'accord ensemble socialistes
insoumis et communistes pour dénoncer la
méthode brutale du gouvernement
ensuite nous communistes nous demandons
la tenue d'un référendum et nous avons
des pc soit dans l'évolution de son sang
mais ce n'est pas le cas de la motion c
est pourquoi une motion de censure alors
que vous savez bien calé quoi qu'il
arrive vouée à l'échec parce que vous
êtes minoritaires la seconde alors on
fait quoi on peut je peux partir
maintenant on peut quitter l'assemblée
nationale fin je veux dire il faut que
l'on accepte dans ce pays que il y a
quand même une opposition quand même
elle existe à l'assemblée nationale dans
le pays elle est forte elle est même
majoritaire dans le pays
à l'assemblée nationale elle est
minoritaire on porte la voix de la
majorité des français des travailleurs
des salariés qui sont contre cette
réforme ils sont majoritaires dans le
pays et nous sommes une poignée de
députés a porté leurs voix
je vais vous faire un rappel 2005 le
traité constitutionnel européen vous
souvenez de ce traité les français ont
voté majoritairement contre
et dans l'hémicycle seuls les députés
communistes ont voté contre 92% des
députés ont voté pour et pourtant ils
étaient minoritaires dans le pays là et
bien cette histoire là il faut l'avoir
en tête
aujourd'hui nous sommes fiers de
représenter la majorité des français et
nous demandons le retrait de cette
réforme qui comme peut-être minoritaire
dans l'hémicycle mais nous irons
jusqu'au bout pour faire entendre du
côté de l'opposition votre collègue
françois ruffin pour la france insoumise
lui demande la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale il demande à aller
beaucoup plus loin ce que vous le suivez
ils demandent la dissolution sa tombe
pas du ciel mais ce que vous êtes
d'accord ces combinés qui dit j'ai
entendu françois la raison je vais
dissoudre
sans sur la motion de censure c'est
l'occasion pour une majorité de députés
que nous allons appeler de voter contre
ce gouvernement juste un peu de vent sur
la solution vous estimez que la démarche
de françois ruffin even donc bas ne
vivait pas oui il s'impliquait appelé la
dissolution ça marchera pas c'est pas
c'est pas comme ça que ça marchera pas
malheureusement jacques chirac en son
temps la mise en oeuvre la dissolution
le président de la république pourrait
considérer que nous sommes dans une
crise importante de notre pays et je le
pense je viens de lire et il pourrait
décider on arrête les frais alors nous
nous disons fait fait un référendum sur
la réforme des retraites qui pourrait
décider de dissoudre
je n'y crois pas une seconde alors
j'espère malgré tout demain convaincre
quelques députés de la majorité à voter
notre motion de censure car des députés
de la majorité ne sont pas contents de
ce qui vient de se passer et de la
manière précoce qui croyez vraiment les
jeux des marcheurs ont voté avec des
cowboys je vous dis mais je suis un
éternel optimiste
les cj propose toujours au coude vous
savez que quand même des députés de la
majorité ne sont pas contents de cette
pratique du 49 3 mai de la limite on va
écouter
je vous pose la question est ce que vous
vous allez voter la motion de la droite
mais je ne partage pas le contenu de
cette motion eu facilement la retraite
est ce parce que alors eux ils poussent
le bouchon la droite ils n'ont jamais
défendu les travailleurs ça se saurait
donc ils sont plutôt du côté des hommes
et prawna et ils sont pour faire
travailler les salariés y compris ceux
qui ont des travaux pénibles beaucoup
plus longtemps donc je ne partage pas le
contenu de leur motion mais sur la forme
comme nous ils dénoncent l' usage du 49
3 et pour que nous soyons forts dans cet
hémicycle
nous avons plutôt à tirano additionner
donc a priori sauf si dans leur propos
est vraiment des choses insupportables
je serais enclin à voter leur motion et
attendait la réciproque bas
j'espère aussi des banques et la
réciproque
mais pourquoi pas on a atterri une
motion censure je rappelle pour ceux qui
nous écoutent que si une majorité de
députés de la vote
ça fait tomber le gouvernement donc
c'est important donc l'objectif c'est de
nous additionner dans notre diversité de
respecter donc les différences que nous
avons les uns et les doutes
nous ne sommes pas dans le même temps
nous sommes tous en désaccord avec le
choix d'écarter toute l'émotion c'est
marine le pen elle l'a dit du coup
est-ce que vous ça vous gêne qu'elle va
de votre motion je ne ferai pas de
commentaire sur celle qui est
complètement absent des débats
elle et ses députés absents ils n'ont
pas été sur la réforme des retraites
c'est pas leur sujet
ea par l'immigration massive et la
fermeture des frontières je ne sais pas
de quoi d'autre il parle donc qu'elle
fasse ce qu'elle veut mais qu'elles ne
viennent pas entacher le combat que nous
menons par sa présence ou son vote à
l'arrêt d'un fils y propose aux
partenaires sociaux de continuer à
enrichir le texte est ce que vous faites
confiance à cette démarche et aux
partenaires sociaux
oui alors c'est ce même gouvernement qui
fait cette offre aujourd'hui c'est ce
même gouvernement qui dit que depuis
deux ans et demi ils ont discuté avec
les partenaires sociaux est donc le
débat assez duré la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs y dantesque en brière a
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il irait de la
conférence devant des enfants tout ça
c'est du grand cinéma quand même y'a pas
eu de négociations avec les syndicats
séparé et cette conférence de
financement elle se fait avec un cadre
figé qui est celui de la règle d'or du
financement de cette réforme
ils n'ont pour levier que l'allongement
de la durée du travail ou la baisse du
niveau des pensions enfin vous imaginez
les syndicats il doit savoir s'il se
coupe le bras gauche doivent décider
s'ils se coupe le bras gauche ou le bras
droit et quand vous le prenez patience
avait bien sûr que non enfin la cfdt
s'est enfermée là dedans ils sont piégés
aujourd'hui rien je comprends que fo et
quitter cette conférence de financement
qui enfin je ne vois pas ce qu'ils
peuvent sortir il a alors le financement
et la gouvernance justement de cette
réforme des retraites
c'est dans le projet de loi organique
qui doit être débattu à l'assemblée
nationale à partir de 12h10
le deuxième volet on sait que le 49-3 ne
peut pas être utilisé une seconde fois
il ya près de deux mille amendements qui
ont été déposés est-ce que vous allez
mener la même bataille déposé beaucoup
de sous amendements sur ce texte
nous allons mener une bataille
parlementaire on va continuer ce que
nous n'avons pas pu faire sur la loi
ordinaire nous allons le faire sur la
loi organique c'est à dire que nous
allons continuer de poser des questions
sur l'âge déquilibre la pénibilité
à quel âge une aide soignante qui
travaille dans un hôpital public et qui
aujourd'hui a le droit de partir à 57
ans parce qu'elle fait partie des
catégories actives
à quel âge pourra-t-elle partir sans
décote avec ce régime par points
cette question je m'en moque
est-ce que les français peuvent savoir
mais non un amendement ça sert à ça
quand on lui quand on nous dit qu'on a
fait de l'obstruction avec des
amendements point virgule
nous avons posé ces questions là ce que
vous comprenez qu'ils n'ont jamais
répondu à ça j'ai posé 20 fois cette
question à quel âge les aides soignantes
vont pouvoir partir en retraite sans
décote je ne pensais pas que c'est
important quand même les égoutiers les
bûcherons les couvreurs ceux qui
travaillent dans le bâtiment
cette fois mais c'est le projet de cette
réforme des retraites
est ce qu'on a le droit de savoir à
quelle sauce vont être mangés
c'est ça le l'objet des amendements
après chacun le sénat sa chambre est ce
que vous souhaitez que les sénateurs
communistes ou bien fassent tout pour
ralentir aussi l'examen du texte qu'ils
optent pour le même type de stratégie
quelle stratégie bien sûr mais pas que
les communistes parce que vous avez
quand même noter que les républicains au
sein de l'assemblée nationale ont eux
aussi ferraillé et longuement pendant
des fois toute une nuit entière à
défendre les avocats par exemple nous
aussi nous les avons défendu mais alors
les airs ils y sont allés 1
ils ont pilonné le gouvernement ils ont
pilonné aussi sur le financement en
disant que ce n'était pas financé ils
ont eux aussi pilonné sur le manque de
financement de cette réforme et au sénat
monsieur larcher a déjà dit qu'il
repoussait l'étude whi ce tag dans qu'il
souhaitait encore une alors justement
autres nice et d'études
ce texte tant que la conférence de
financement n'avait pas rendu ses
conclusions
tant mieux vous êtes d'accord mais bien
sûr vous allez me dire que la conférence
de financement elle servait à rien ou
des oeufs
je les comprends dans leurs démarches de
la même manière le gouvernement il doit
dire dans ce texte à trous il ya
tellement de trucs à plus de matières
d'ailleurs il doit quand même dire
qu'elle est le financement de cette
réforme que les français soient éclairés
ils ont dit que la part des richesses
consacrée aux retraites dans notre pays
mais allez passer de 14% à 12 089 ça
fait 23 milliards de rien en moins
alarmant où ils vont trouver cet argent
est ce que c'est en faisant travailler
les français plus longtemps
c'est ce que nous nous disons ou alors
ils vont faire tourner la planche à
billets jean pierre rousselle il y à
jeudi un soutien aussi les républicains
qui met la pression sur le gouvernement
sur la question du financement on n'a
pas les mêmes objectifs mais c'est une
vraie question
j'espère qu'ils seront aussi accusé
d'obstruction comme nous l'avons été
bien parce que c'est
il y a les retraites puis l'autre sujet
de préoccupation c'est l'épidémie de
coronavirus trois morts en france et on
a dépassé le cap de 100 cas décelés dans
notre pays brigitte oui le corps un
virus qui préoccupe fortement le
gouvernement
est ce que dans l'opinion finalement ça
n'a pas remplacé le débat sur les
retraites qui passent au second plan
ah ben je pense que le premier ministre
lors du conseil des ministres de samedi
dernier a opportunément profité de cette
épidémie qui arrive sur le pays pour
brutalement utiliser le 49 3 en 10 ans
comme ça ça va passer au second plan de
l'actualité je pense sincèrement vous
dire la même chose je le sens
non pas pour empêcher une motion de
censure mais on voit bien avec il y a un
vrai risque épidémique avec l'angoissé
des français la peur de nos concitoyens
de cette épidémie qui arrive sur le pays
avec des mesures de confinement à
prendre d'interdiction de rassemblement
à dire que c'est tentant d'utiliser le
49-3 de faire passer le texte
brutalement et puis de dire et j'attends
qu'ils
interdisent de manifester parce que ça
nous pend au nez en plus oui donc
qu'elle a repéré oui vous avez fait un
tweet
effectivement vous avez remis en cause
l'interdiction de rassemblements de plus
de cinq mille personnes
vous avez dit que c'est la porte ouverte
à l'interdiction de manifester mais ils
ont bien dit que c'est 5000 personnes
dans un lieu confiné donc on n'est pas
du tout aux mêmes prestations parce que
je ne m'étais pas la charrue avant les
boeufs hier n'a pas trompé de chemin
j'attire l'attention sur cette menace et
j'ai fait ça en même temps qu'ils vont
annoncer que le marathon de paris était
annulé six mois les connexions sifflé
donc il y à bien des manifestations des
personnes du monde andres il ya des
manifestations de plein air qui ont été
annulés et donc de la même manière
j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas des mesures
d'interdiction qui se prendront contre
les manifestations
mais du coup je redis que le
gouvernement saisit opportunément cette
crise épidémique pour utiliser le 49-3
c'est lâche de tabarre il y à
véritablement une forme de lâcheté de
retard de ne pas vouloir affronter un
débat et de ne pas exploiter le
mouvement social mais même à croquer
annuler tous ses déplacements prévus y
compris le dîner du crif pour vous et
bien c'est plutôt rassurant ou c'est
inquiétant je ne sais pas ce qu'il avait
prévu lors de ses déplacements ni
combien de personnes il était prévu au
dîner du crif
en tout état de cause il y à des mesures
à prendre face à cette épidémie
il y a les scientifiques qui font des
préconisations parfois même rassurante
en disant bon c'est pas si grave que ça
et je pense que la responsabilité des
politiques c'est d'aller plus loin que
les scientifiques
je vous donne un avis personnel oui bon
je suis pas dans la majorité je suis pas
en situation de prendre les décisions
prenait personnellement c'est pas là moi
je dis qu'en tant que responsable
politique on doit répondre à l'angoissé
des gens et on doit prendre des mesures
de précaution
et si chacun d'entre nous nous avons des
proches fragile au niveau de la santé ou
si nous avons peur que d'être touché par
cette épidémie je pense que l'on
attendait
d'une autorité politique qu'il prenne
des mesures pour les maximales approche
et donc je crois qu'il faut aller plus
loin juste que ce que préconisent les
scientifiques et plus loin ça veut dire
pour vous remporté les municipales
ben écoute et on verra où ça on sera
dans quinze jours mais le vote avant que
je sais dans 13 jours le premier 13
jours et ça va aller vite je pense
j'imagine comment ça se déroule dans les
bureaux de vote de ma commune à
saint-amand-les-eaux dans le nord dans
les bureaux de vote
il ya du monde mais pas tant que ça il
ya combien dans un bureau de vote au
grand max en même temps il va y avoir 30
40 personnes n'a pas brillé à nu des
jeunes si il y à le gel pour se laver
les mains
ensuite il faut que la question c'est
est-ce qu'il ya matière à annuler les
municipales ou pas aujourd'hui je dis
non comme le dit joe vernement
aujourd'hui je dis donc comme le dit le
gouvernement j'étais à matignon et nous
en avons parlé lors de la rencontre à
matignon
et ce n'est pas du tout à l'ordre du
jour alors en plus en plus je
comprendrais pas que l'on y imagine sa
et qu'en même temps les temples de la
consommation les grandes surfaces tous
ces lieux où se concentrent des milliers
de personnes confinées pour le coup cela
continue de fonctionner table je
m'interroge même s'il n'y a pas eu
si on ne dirait pas ou pour ne pas
abîmer l'économie on va laisser
l'épidémie peut-être se développer mais
surtout il ne faudrait pas abîmer
l'économie de ces salles d'étape je
pense que là dessus il faudrait prendre
le risque se canaliser l'économie
jugeait qu'il ya des gros endiguer les
écouter la question jugé qu il ya des
grands incohérences aujourd'hui dans les
mesures qui sont prises par le
gouvernement
il ya les transports publics qui
continuent et puis d'un autre côté on
interdit les rassemblements avec 5000
personnes
disneyland qui reste ouvert voilà c'est
parce que je la voulais à travers donc
ma commune à saint-amand où il ya des
personnels qui sont rentrés de vacances
ce week-end nous on a repris l'école
aujourd'hui
eh bien il rentre de vénissy ou de
lombardie il ya quatre jours on leur a
dit dès que vous rentrez vous restez
chez vous vous reprenez pas le travail
vous mettez pas les enfants à l'école
parce que vous venez d'une zone à risque
et puis hier soir on nous dit non c'est
bon maintenant ils peuvent reprendre le
travail
c'est pas grave le virus voyage mais je
me mets à la place des personnes qui
travaillent avec eux ou des enfants qui
sont à l'école et puis qui vont voir
leur coller leurs copains revenir de
lombardie de vénissy mais l'été les gens
voient s'ériger ce que est ce que là il
n'aurait pas fallu maintenir ces
périodes de confinement pour ceux qui
viennent gruger les zones à risque alors
on voit que les fonctionnaires par
exemple du louvre on demandait à exercer
leur droit de retrait depuis j'ai tout
serait que 300 conducteurs de bus de
l'essonne aussi ont doublé leur droit de
retrait ce que vous trouvez que c'est
une bonne décision
je comprends je remercie tout le monde
fait cela et vous imaginez plus de
fonctionnaires à 20 si tout le monde
devant de son droit de retrait ou pu
découvrir que l'économie est alors je
vous pose la même question vous si vous
avez une collègue qui revient là
directement de de vénissy mais lassé des
droits des retraités du trois cas graves
incidents avaient conçu avec le droit
d'exercer votre droit de retrait vous
voilà qui n'est pas une question de
fonctionnaires ou de salariés les
fonctionnaires ont le droit de retrait
peuvent l'exercer
mais comprenons les quand même enfin on
dit que ce cette épidémie ce virus tue
dix fois plus que la grippe c'est quand
même beaucoup alors il n'y a pas
beaucoup de cas donc ya pas beaucoup de
morts mais si demain le virus se propage
et si c'est plusieurs dizaines faut pas
faire confiance au gouvernement quand il
prend un certain nombre de mesures
il ya beaucoup de complotisme le vois je
vais vous dire franchement n'étant pas
en responsabilité je n'ai pas toutes les
informations
donc j'ai bien du mal à avancer et à
dire ce qu'il faudrait faire
donc je ne donnerai pas de conseils jeu
porte ici les angoisses que j'entends
dans ma circonscription et dans ma
commune des angoisses réelle et sincère
et donc ces personnes qui vont être en
contact avec ceux qui reviennent de
zones à risque à qui on dit vous pouvez
reprendre le travail il n'y a plus de
problème ça peut créer de langoat et
donc je les compte dernière question de
théâtre rester sur le volet économique
bruno le maire dit que l'état prendra en
charge les pertes des entreprises
est ce que pour vous eh bien c'est la
bonne réponse oui oui oui je l' ai même
dit au gouvernement
demandez est-ce que les mêmes mesures
qui ont été prises un petit peu les
mêmes qui ont été prises dans le cadre
des manifs gilet jaune
eh bien ce sont des mesures qui peuvent
être prises pour des pme ou salarié ou
deux ne viennent pas travailler ou sont
confinés ça peut effectivement pénalisé
la production c'est normal de pouvoir
les accompagner
une petite question des téléspectateurs
la surveillait live c'est christian léon
qui nous envoie cette question on dit
que c'est jean luc mélenchon qui aurait
piégé le gouvernement sûr et qui aurait
amené le gouvernement à déclencher 49,3
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous pas je
vais pas répondre à la place de jean luc
mélenchon donc on dit que c'est lui
est-ce que vous lui accorder ce crédit
est ce que c'est grâce à jean luc
mélenchon alors je vais répondre pour
moi oui voila moi personnellement nous
avons déposé dix mille amendements
jamais je n'ai souhaitait le 49-3 jamais
je n'ai même dit je me suis vanter de
faire de l'obstruction
jamais je n'ai parlé de guérilla
parlementaire de trancher jamais je n'ai
jamais je n'ai utilisé ces mots je
voulais je veux le débat sur le fond
donc je veux la vérité sur le grade avec
la france accueille donc nous avons fait
voulait nous avons exercé notre droit
d'amendement et le gouvernement avec
brutalité il ya mis fin
viens là ce que je constate bien merci
tab merci brigitte et place maintenant
aux parlementaires qu'ils nous
rejoignent sur le plateau d'audition
publique avenue
nos parlementaires qui sont avec nous ce
soir sandra beauté un bon soir écoutez
la république en marche de l'isère et
vous avez été en pointe dans le débat
sur les retraites on vous a beaucoup vu
même parfois avec des lapsus avec un
lapsus et jean-raymond hugo n'est
sénateur apparenté l'est républicain de
l'essonne dont soir vous aussi vous êtes
évidemment la réforme des retraites on
va commencer par sandra mottin à propos
du 49-3 bien évidemment alors fabien
roussel vous venez de vous dire que vous
ne souhaitiez pas faire de l'obstruction
malgré tout avec treize mille
amendements le groupe gdr a été en
pointe dont 1184 fois l'amendement qui
remplaçait universel par inéquitable
mais à part ça vous êtes le secrétaire
national du parti communiste
un parti qui a une histoire liée à celle
de la france et de la résistance une
histoire liée au conseil national de la
résistance qui a posé les bases de la
protection sociale française et de la
sécurité sociale vous êtes le
représentant d'un parti républicain qui
défend les valeurs de la république et
le respect de ses institutions
et pourtant depuis quatre semaines
maintenant vous vous êtes mis dans la
route jean luc mélenchon qui n'a plus
rien de républicain qui cherchent à
détruire les institutions dans la nôtre
pour imposer sa volonté à la france sa
6e république
la question c'est donc le secrétaire
national du parti communiste français
qui adresser ma question
ne pensez-vous pas que vous alliez ainsi
avec un homme qui cherche à déstabiliser
la république qui prône la révolution
pour servir ses ambitions hégémoniques
vous trahissez votre histoire aux
valeurs votre parti vos militants
ne pensez vous pas aussi qu'à côté de
jean-luc mélenchon et ses disciples
vous êtes devenus inaudibles au risque
de ne plus faire apparaître votre
différence la réponse de fabien roussel
aujourd'hui si la république est abîmée
c'est à cause de votre majorité
l'attitude de votre chef
le président de la république et la
manière dont il refuse d'entendre la
colère qui s'exprime dans le pays depuis
des semaines et des semaines
refusant de négocier avec les syndicats
imposant ce texte au sein de l'assemblée
nationale alors qu'une majorité de nos
concitoyens ne veulent pas de cette
réforme et utilisant le 49-3 après 13
jours de discussions et la discussion de
dix mille amendements
malgré tout quand même et donc ouais on
pourrait venir sur les cinq mille
amendements déclaré irrecevable parce
que justement comme les nôtres qui
demandait la retraite à 60 ans il ya
déclaré irrecevable je ne fais pas la
danse et des gens ce débat mais comme
quoi cinq mille amendements rejetés
énormément parce que parce que ont
demandé la retraite à 60 ans entre bref
ce qui abîme la république c'est votre
majorité et je le dis solennellement
vous prenez un risque majeur de dégoûter
nos concitoyens d'aller voter d'aller
vous élevez est-ce que vous des départs
et est ce que n'a jamais qu'on vote
repart est ce que vous vous remarqué
comme universelles je ne défends pas le
parti communiste français mais vous êtes
jetés fait en général les français je
défends nos concitoyens je défends le
monde du travail les salariés du privé
et du public
ceux qui aujourd'hui peine à gagner leur
vie dignement en travaillant en
travaillant parfois péniblement et avec
des salaires de misère et qui ont peur
en plus de leur salaire de misère
d'avoir une pension de misère je porte
leur voix et je les défenses à
l'hémicycle
est-ce que vous mesurez que nous sommes
aujourd'hui une minorité dans
l'assemblée nationale a porté la voix
d'une majorité de tous les citoyens pas
répondu à un genou et bien aujourd'hui
même les valeurs aujourd'hui les valeurs
du parti communiste français sont celles
de la défense du monde du travail de la
dignité du monde du travail
et heureusement que nous sommes là dans
l'hémicycle pour les représenter pour
faire éclater la vérité sur la shd
équilibre sur l'âge à partir duquel ses
salariés du public et du privé pourront
partir sans décote jeu m'avait posé au
moins 100 fois la question justement
jamais nous n'avons eu la réponse des
questions de fond à ce sont des
questions de fond qui intéresse j'aurai
mon hugonnet le moins
voilà on va être certainement pas être
d'accord c'est une évidence mais comme
l'a rappelé le premier ministre il ya
trois leviers sur la retraite
le taux le montant des pensions et l'âge
de toute cotisation le taux de
cotisation est là sur le taux de
cotisation excusez-moi d'autres
cotisations on augmente le coût du
travail
si on touche aux pensions vous voyez
déjà ce sens qu'elle les baisses si on
les baisse vous voyez déjà dans quel
état est le pays il reste plus que l'âge
comment repousser l'âge de départ à la
retraite et ça c'est une évidence pour
moi pour d'autres et pour une majorité
maintenant ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
la caricature de dire pourrait demander
par exemple un déménageur de monter un
piano 7e étage à 65 ans est grotesque
quelle est votre position sur la
pénibilité puisque c'est là à mon sens
que repose le point névralgique
d'abord je conteste le fait que pour
parler de la réforme des retraites
il fallait rester il faudrait rester
enfermés dans ces trois leviers que vous
venez de citer les syndicats des
syndicats et des forces politiques dont
le parti communiste français demande ont
justement est ce que l'on puisse aller
chercher d'autres formes de cotisations
notamment sur le capital pourquoi n'y at
il pas de cotisations sociales sur le
capital sur les revenus financiers par
exemple ils sont exonérés de cotisations
eux et pourtant il n'y en a jamais eu
autant la part des richesses attribués
aux salaires ou au capital et les
parties en faveur du capital et ils ne
cotisent pas voilà les régimes spéciaux
que nous nous avons dénoncé et non nous
proposons qu'il cotise et c'est avec
cette cotisation que nous pourrions
financer une véritable prise en compte
de la pénibilité
nous proposons nous que ceux qui ont des
travaux pénibles puissent partir dès
l'âge de 55 ans parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous les rencontrons dans nos
circonscriptions vous en rencontrez
certaines malcolm x ce qui à 55 ans sont
cassés week assez physiquement et
parfois moralement par le travail ils
n'ont pas d'autre alternative que d'être
prises en charge par la solidarité
nationale c'est où les allocation
handicapée ou c'est des systèmes de
prêts
retraité de dépasser 50 agrément prix
dont savent pas une retraite dit le
président veut dire sombre du jeu je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure il est impossible
de laisser croire même si pour moi le
seul levier c'est l'âge
évidemment il est impossible de laisser
croire qu'on va faire travailler plus
longtemps jusqu'à 65 ans des personnes
qui ont des métiers particulièrement
pénible et comme vous le dites à 55 ans
ont cassé parce qu'ils ont des charges
lourdes ou autre dont les autres c'est
65 et c'est une évidence nous sommes les
seuls en europe à encore à essayer de
faire rêver les gens à essayer de faire
rêver les gens en leur mentant sur
l'état financier de notre pays c'est un
peu nabeul mais s'excentre un autre
parce que justement il ya quatre
critères de pénibilité qui ne sont pas
prises en compte par le gouvernement qui
ont été retirés dans le cadre de la loi
qui a été discuté l'année dernière et
donc nous demandons comme d'autres
syndicats jusqu'à la cfdt à ce que ces
quatre critères de pénibilité soit remis
posture proximité avec produit chez les
travailleurs pit nous nous rejoignons de
cela ils n'ont rien voulu entendre ce
qu'on dit sur tout et je crois que ça
c'est important et ça se retrouve
d'ailleurs dans texte qui va être
présenté demain par le premier ministre
au parlement
on a voulu travailler d'abord sur la
prévention parce qu'avant de dire que
les gens sont cassées le mieux c'est
d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils ne le
soient pas et qu'ils puissent se
reconvertir donc je crois aussi que on
est encore en train de travailler
aujourd'hui avec les partenaires sociaux
vous disiez qu'on travaillait pas avec
eux c'est faux on travaille bien sûr
avec eux à trouver des solutions pour la
réparation mais la prévention je crois
que ça va être quelque chose d'essentiel
pour les années à venir où seule la
prévention il coûtait moi j'ai rencontré
salariés du bâtiment reçu à ma
permanence
il ya quinze jours il ya 54 ans il a
plaqué effet d'électricité pendant toute
sa vie est cassé vous vais lui parler de
prévention lui aujourd'hui il a besoin
d'être de partir en retraite et de pas
être prise en charge par l'allocation
adulte handicapé or c'est le seul
recours qu'il a donc quand on a
travaillé toute sa vie dans une pme
une petite boîte c'est qu'on a été
coureur et qu'on est couvreur un gamin
aujourd'hui qu'ils rendent coureurs et
qui monte sur les toits et il va faire
ça pendant 20 ans commença séance il est
à prendre là ils comment je vais leur
proposer quelque chose quelqu'un vous
allez reposer à un patron de pme pour
tenir compte de ce gamin quand ils sont
quatre ou cinq dans l'entreprise vous
allez vous lui proposez quoi une charte
un tutorat qu'est ce que vous allez
créer une forme à une vraie formation
qui a dit fientes qui sera possible
grâce à son compte personnel de
formation alors bref vous vouliez aussi
parlé du corona ville soit tout à fait
est resté justement sur ce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure notamment sur la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
parce que la crise du coronavirus là par
son ampleur mondiale elle a mis en
lumière la fragilité d'une partie de nos
industries on peut citer par exemple les
difficultés de l'industrie automobile
dont la plupart des pièces détachées
sont fabriqués en chine ou même de
l'industrie pharmaceutique dont 80 à 85%
des principes actifs sont fabriqués en
chine et donc on a besoin aujourd'hui de
réindustrialiser la france est ce qu'on
fait depuis deux ans à recréer des
emplois industriels un peu partout en
france mais on l'a fait effectivement
parce que on a rendu nos entreprises
compétitives ou parler sans arrêt de
taxer capitale comment imaginez-vous
pouvoir réindustrialiser la france et
retrouvé de l'emploi industriel en
taxant systématiquement de capital comme
vous souhaitez pas ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure qu'il fallait une cotisations
sociales sur les revenus financiers pour
financer nos systèmes de retraites ça
c'est une de nos propositions mais nous
avons une autre proposition au parti
communiste français
nous disons aussi qu'il faut
révolutionner nos modes de production
ça nous permettra aussi de répondre aux
défis écologiques
nous devons produire autrement nous
devons produire localement produire en
france parce que ce sera bon pour le
climat au lieu d'importer des produits
qui viennent d'asie produisons ici ce
sera bon
l'emploi et ce sera bon pour nos impôts
parce que les entreprises qui
s'installeront ici perron des impôts ici
donc ce sera bon pour le budget de la
france
au lieu de cela aujourd'hui on laisse
des entreprises dce par est délocalisée
au nom de la compétitivité et de la
rentabilité des dividendes com -
whirlpool amiens où le gars il a préféré
fermer l'usiné
amiens pour s'installer en pologne où
les salaires sont de 549 euros
c'est quoi votre projet de société c'est
de s'aligner sur sa 149 euros par mois
ou c'est de faire en sorte que la france
dise non cette entreprise elle reste là
et je préfère la soutenir et participer
au capital de cette entreprise pour
construit pour continuer à produire des
machines à laver sur le sol français
c'est ça que nous devons le faire ça
c'est d'une autre ambition français et
continue à augmenter
mais par contre effectivement ce qui a
changé c'est que on a commencé une
harmonisation de la fiscalité des
entreprises
ce qui a fait de la france l'un des
premiers tout premiers pays pour
l'investissement en europe depuis deux
ans donc je ne vois pas comment votre
idée de produire autrement qui pour
l'instant fait beaucoup de mousse et ses
bons mots je viens de vous et joliment
crds et man men on entend dire
uniquement france d'abord c'est oublier
qu'on a des partenaires européens avec
qui on peut travailler avec qui on doit
travailler mais en même temps ça ne me
dit pas grand chose de la façon dont
vous et je vous dis que moi je n'aurais
pas sur des territoires jeu et donc vous
allez les actes dont vous allez rendre
les territoires attractifs je n'aurais
pas laissé world poule amiens déménagé
en pologne
je serais rentré dans le capital de
cette entreprise est la différence
la différence entre vous et nous on est
sur les sociétés c'est que vous vous
parlez à des avocats fiscalistes à des
fonds de pension tandis que moi je
préfère parler à des industriels à des
patrons bien mais véritablement
capitaine d'industrie qui ont envie de
produire ici et qui ont besoin d'être
soutenus à fond c'est pour ça que le
parti communiste français d'aujourd'hui
par l'otan aux ouvriers qu'aux patrons
mais à ce qui va le produire pas à ceux
qui veulent pas faire de la spéculation
boursière parlé toute la différence
avant de parler d'autres sujets avec
jean raymond hugo n'est pas ce que vous
voulez parler d'autres sujets j'aimerais
que vous continuiez sandra matin parce
que vous
évoquée toujours à propos des
difficultés liées aux coronavirus le
sort des agriculteurs
oui le sort des agriculteurs donc le
salon de l'agriculture s'est tenu la
semaine dernière il a fermé ses portes
sur une grande inquiétude de la part de
nos producteurs laitiers notamment qui
voit après une année 2010 9 qui avait
connu une jolie embellie grâce notamment
à la loi il ya dix ans ils voient les
cours du lait chuté à cause du problème
du corps à des virus et de la chine qui
ne fait plus aucune commande
moi je voulais savoir puisque vous
fustigez les accords internationaux tels
que l'état qui garantissent pourtant à
nos agriculteurs des ouvertures sur les
marchés avec des sécurités sur les
produits quelles solutions vous proposez
et notamment dans le cadre de la
nouvelle pac
quelles solutions pour venir en aide aux
filiales de drague parenthèse savoir les
sénateurs jean raymond bucolique a pas
l'air d'être d'accord il faudrait
demander à mon collègue si vous dites ça
à mon collègue daniel gremillet qui est
sénateur et qui est producteur justement
de lait de fromage et autres je vous
garantis que vous dites ça à cheval de
bois il vous donne à coups de pierres
bon alors la question de cendres à votre
cause des essais un bien vous cet
endroit importations de fromages gras
soit c'est à ce stade les producteurs de
lait et ceux qui ont des vaches
laitières et chez moi dans l'amandinois
justement c'est ça la principale
activité des paysans des agriculteurs
qu'est ce que vous feriez pour eu une
intervention la pac avant ça avant ça
ils ont souffert de la disparition des
quotas
avant ça ils ont dix ils ont souffert et
souffre encore de la concurrence
déloyale du lait qui vient de pologne
d'allemagne de slovénie qui est produit
à moindre coût et qui rentre chez nous
sans taxes sans rien parce que c'est la
concurrence libre et non faussée
donc ils souffrent déjà aujourd'hui d'un
marché européen qui n'est pas juste pour
eux et nos producteurs nos agriculteurs
aujourd'hui on leur demande de d'avoir
des des contrôles plus dur d'être plus
et les sur la production de leurs
produits que ne le sont les voisins
européens
pourtant c'est les mêmes rexel la même
europe mais nos voisins européens
non au moins de règles à mettre en
oeuvre que les producteurs français
c'est de ça dont il souffre d'abord
répondre 7 il faudrait plutôt soutenir
nos agriculteurs et leur garantir un
prix du lait aujourd'hui sont dans les
mains de lactalis à l'heure et lactalis
c'est monsieur baigner et monsieur bene
c'est le huitième fortune de france
alors allez leur dire va passer de
l'agriculture à la culture parce que
jean raymond hugonnet il est membre de
la commission culture au sénat et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la mise en place du
pass culture c'est aides pour les jeunes
qui étaient mises en place par le
gouvernement actuel justement et qui est
testé dans plusieurs départements
absolument alors comme vous l'avez dit
j'appartiens la commission culture
présidée par catherine morin desailly et
je voulais vous poser la question
directement pour vous est ce une bonne
idée ce pass culture qui vise donc une
tranche d'âge à 18 ans ou si un chèque
de 500 à 1 sec de ces jeunes douala toi
dans certains départements pour la spa
lors des des départements tests on a
grandi ce nombre de départements tests
et nous apprenons plus les choses par
d'ailleurs je le dis par la presse les
médias bien informées plutôt que par des
communications qui nous sont faites mais
passons sur ce détail pour vous est ce
une façon de démocratiser la culture
auprès de la classe d'âge des 18 ans oui
je pense que c'est une bonne initiative
d'ailleurs le département du val de
marne qui est dirigé par un président du
conseil départemental qui est communiste
donc c'est pas pour rien qu'il a
souhaité lui s'en saisir et métro 9 donc
de permettre à ce que des jeunes
puissent avoir accès à des activités
culturelles est tout à fait c'est plutôt
une bonne chose
je dirais pour modérer que justement les
communes comme on est en pleine période
municipal ont de plus en plus de mal à
pouvoir abondé ou participer à ce genre
d'initiative
parce que leur budget ont été diminués
parce que ce gouvernement a contraint
les budgets des collectivités ils ont
baissé les dotations des régions des
régions des départements et des agglos
dites pas que c'est faux enfin sonné à
la commission des finances
l on soit elle et les dépenses ont été
gelés et elles n'ont pas augmenté au
rythme qu'elle aurait dû augmenter pour
pouvoir répondre à leurs dépenses donc
au final elle
menacions parcours balisé avec les
grands noms collecte les eaux les
réduire les frais de fonctionnement et
d'avoir plus d'argent pour les
investissements et ben voilà donc
réduire les frais donc réfléchi
effectivement les communes font les
frais de vol politique
elles subissent des politiques
d'austérité et je regrette qu'elle ne
puisse donc pas plus pouvoir soutenir
des initiatives qui favorisent l'accès à
l'emploi causé voudrais vous parler d'un
livre
ah oui parce que ce que vous avez
apporté une couverture absolument
absolument mais je vous aviez écrit
coécrit avec andré chassaigne en octobre
2008 le manifeste pour un parti
communiste du 21e siècle
je m'intéresse dans le brouhaha des fois
médiatique d'aujourd'hui à des gens qui
font avancer cette réflexion excusez moi
je n'ai pas d'actions avec david djaïz
ni à sa maison d'édition
mais ce monsieur a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle slow démocratie que je vous
engage à lire et l'un et l'autre vous
avez voulu vous aurez à huy ah oui que
j'ai lu et que je suis en train de
relire d'accord c'est un garçon qui
avaient pourtant voulu en parler fabien
roussel a d'abord et d'une parce que à
l'heure où il est de bon ton de fustiger
les élites de notre pays moi je les
admire qu'elles soient culturelles
sportives pôles politiques
à 29 ans quand on est énarque et
normalien sait qu'on doit avoir quand
même le cerveau un peu bien fait et une
certaine intelligence ce monsieur david
djaïz que je ne connais pas mais que je
vais rencontrer parce que je pense qu'il
est exceptionnel il a ressorti le
triangle ce qu'on appelle le triangle de
roznik qui est le triangle
d'incompatibilité ça rejoint le débat
que vous avez eu tout à l'heure et que
le pays doit avoir
il est impossible dans un triangle dans
ce triangle là de faire se rejoindre les
trois extrémités que sont d'un côté
l'état nation de l'autre côté la
démocratie et le troisième la
mondialisation l'hyper mondialisation
c'est exactement au coeur de votre débat
de tout à l'heure c'est ce qui vous
opposait ce qui oppose oui il ya sans
cesse qui oppose plus que fabien roussel
et vous même c'est ce à quoi le pays
doit réfléchir à la bd tout à l'heure
vous nous mettez en avant les contrats
internationaux
tout ça les français le savent qu'ils
soient communistes républicains ou
autres ils savent très bien que des
décisions très importantes qui impactent
leur vie au quotidien ne sont plus
prises en france alors je vous laisse
poser la question à fabien roussel est
donc dans ce triangle d'incompatibilité
je le rappelle entre pas de les dater
reçurent j'attendais l'état-nation la
démocratie et l'hyper mondialisation
choisissez votre couple camarades c'est
l'état nation et la démocratie qui vont
moins et pour nous communistes français
vont ensemble sans mettre de côté la
mondialisation puisque nous ne la bat
l'ayons pas d'un revers de main nous
défendons une autre forme de
mondialisation qui n'est pas celle des
traités de libre échange mais qui est
celle des coopérations consentis ont
chaque peuple s'y retrouvent aujourd'hui
cette mondialisation elle se fait au
bénéfice de multinationales et de
rentiers pas au bénéfice des peuples et
donc ses sept
ces nouvelles coopérations que nous
souhaitions que nous souhaitons
privilégier y compris au sein de
l'europe c'est-à-dire que nous
contestons cette construction européenne
et nous préférerions nous une europe des
nations qui respecte les peuples et la
souveraineté de chaque site un vrai
sujet et le fédéralisme l'europe des
nations alors le vocabulaire de marine
du vocabulaire
sumann passionné non lentement permettez
moi de reprendre leur mère leur arrivée
après le parti communiste français et le
concept de nation et des exactement mais
le concept de nation d'état nation et
d'europe des nations le parti communiste
français l'a défendu des 79
quand on a vu cette europe se construire
fédéral que nous avons toujours contesté
et donc nous oui nous défendons le
concept d'une nation qui protège ses
citoyens et le concept de république
issu de la révolution française qui
respecte tous ses citoyens
indistinctement de ses origines de sa
religion ou de saisie avez réussi votre
coup j'aurais voilà c'était mon facteur
qui fatalement je vais la fraction de
seconde je peux vous garantir le lien je
vous le dis je vous le dis clairement à
tous les deux si chacun comprend bien ce
qui est dit là dedans il y a une voix
pour notre pays que l'on soit communiste
que son nom soit en marche mais ça
existe sauf qu'il faut quelqu'un pour
l'expliquer aux gens le transmettre et
l'incarner et aujourd'hui et même les
mecs on n'est pas cette personne alors
bon ça c'est pour sandra boutin mais
alors on va vous laisser mes choses vous
poser une question qu'ils ôtent auriez
par rose regard sur figaro live à propos
de la situation en ce moment à la
frontière entre la grèce et la turquie
qu'est ce que le parti communiste
propose comme solution face à l'arrivée
massive entre parenthèses est sévèrement
réprimée de migrants à la frontière
c'est horrible et c'est là aussi
voilà en quoi je conteste cette
construction européenne
vous rendez compte que monsieur macron
madame merkel ont fait le choix de
négocier avec monsieur erdogan qui est
un truand dictateur qu'est ce que lui
dirait contient les migrer les
immigrants qui viennent de syrie les
actus les gars derrière des barbelés
mais surtout qu'ils ne viennent pas chez
nous eauze et cuir erdogan est en train
de dire si vous venez pas me soutenir
dans ma guerre contre assad
eh bien je les lâche je lâche les
migrants y laissant système com com du
corps mais comme la question c'est celle
qui la clé j'ai demandé aujourd'hui j'ai
fait une déclaration aujourd'hui le
parti communiste français demande
d'abord à monsieur macron de saisir le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu il faut que
cessent les bombardements en syrie il
faut arrêts
t cette guerre là bas et donc erdogan
doit rentrer chez lui et la deuxième
chose à bord
et la deuxième chose c'est que il y a
trois millions de réfugiés syriens qui
sont là à la frontière turque
enfin quand même dans notre grand
continent et dans cette belle europe
il n'y a pas les moyens aujourd'hui de
porter secours à ces personnes ils
doivent rester derrière ces barbelés la
batture sont dotés d'un mouvement
moi ce qui m'a choqué ce week-end c'est
surtout la réaction des grecs sur l'île
de lesbos on voit vraiment que le
nationalisme le populisme est en train
de gagner du terrain dans ce pays qui
est celui de la démocratie personne
notre démocratie et ça ça m'inquiète à
languédias meraz il a vot merci cendres
a noté un merci jean remo où il venait
d'être venu sur le plateau d'auditions
publiques
merci c'est yves thréard qui va arriver
maintenant c'est pas bien
c'est pas terminé ça vient comment
voulez vous qu'ils existent sont ils
très récemment qu'on soit bien aussi
aller vous très bon livre un slot
démocratie exc
j'ai découvert un très bon livre euh je
vais exercer un petit droit de suite
mais rapide tout à l'heure je crains que
vous soyez mal exprimé c'est pour ça je
voudrais être sûr de ce que vous avez
dit vous n'allez pas nous avait pas dit
que la grande distribution
profitez du cognac coronavirus pour
vendre du thé du café des pâtes et
demandé aux français de faire des
provisions en stock
non vous avez pas dit ça je je je ne
voudrais pas qu'on l'a compris et on
sent que je préfère ce je ne voudrais
pas que je comprends pas pourquoi le
gouvernement dit on le virus circule
donc on va laisser circuler et on ne
prend pas on ne fait pas le choix de
confiner des territoires ne fait pas le
choix d'interdire justement la fermeture
de deux peut-être deux temples de la
consommation beaucoup de personnes
espèrent voir j'ai voulu entrer oui des
supermarchés ou d où des zones
commerciales et les veaux les accusés de
rien c'est normal
d'accord on est là non non non les verts
on les accuse un ange 2 elle accuse rien
du tout ces jeux j'interroge le
gouvernement en faisant ça l'accord
était pourquoi ne vont-ils pas jusqu'à
demander à ce que ces lieux soient
fermés parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de monde confiné dans des
endroits où il fait chaud on se touche
maintenant alors on ferme des concerts à
la ferme quand un virus 49,3 est ce que
cette disposition qui vous met en émoi
est-ce que vous n'allez pas vous servir
du levier des municipales pour justement
et bien essayé de faire en sorte que le
gouvernement ne soit sanctionné à
travers ce vote parce qu'il a utilisée
43 mais d'abord les les électeurs
élections municipales doivent déterminer
leur vote en fonction des enjeux locaux
c'est à dire à qui je donne la ville et
pas de saut dans l'inconnu
accusant donne les clés de la ville ça
c'est important mais je dis aussi que
après ce qui vient de se passer là au
parlement et avec cette réforme des
retraites qui est imposée de manière
brutale
je dis aussi que ce bulletin de vote il
peut être
utilisé aussi pour sanctionner ceux qui
vont porter l'étiquette la république en
marche sur le grand léjon uzein les
edouard philippe
les darmanin léry esther et compagnie
sont responsables de ce qui se passe
dans le pays il doit aussi hâtif
sanctionné pour cela à localement
sanctionne mais c'est pas pour autant
que vous approuvez comme au havre ville
qui a été communiste très longtemps que
là les affiches de campagne ou même la
permanence du candidat philippe soit
taguées et dégradées jets de pierres
vous approuvez ça la dégradation des
biens journée toujours condamné sans
difficulté je dis aussi que au havre où
jean-paul lecoq conduit une liste
citoyenne way est soutenue par les
forces de gauche et avec des écologistes
eh bien ils ont besoin d'un maire à
temps plein et je ne comprends pas
qu'aujourd'hui le premier ministre qui a
fort à faire
il a dit qu'il rêvait syrie devrait
continuer d'être premier ministre de
mener campagne du bout des lèvres là-bas
et de dire en plus
et je serai pas mr m'enfin on est dans
la vème république qui nous ont fait
voter une loi sur la moralisation de la
vie publique et on a aujourd'hui un
premier ministre candidat qui dit on va
bien vous celle-ci jamais je suis et je
serai pas mr enfin vous et vous trouvez
pas que c'est énorme que c'est du beau
changer car les électeurs à bien vous
elle vous avez mis le doigt sur quelque
chose a dit nous là-bas au havre on est
avec les écologistes avec socialisme est
alors les citoyens des citoyens ce qui
est intéressant avec le parti communiste
c'est que vous êtes à je dirais à des
amours à géométrie variable
je prends ivry sur seine je prends saint
denis deux grandes villes deux bastions
du parti communiste elle pas plus au
monde
je vous ai pris ces deux là pourquoi
parce que là vous avez face à vous face
au parti communiste au candidat du parti
communiste des villes qui sont tues
depuis très longtemps par le parti
communiste est bien une coalition de
gauche avec la france à soubise
kolo gist le partage mais vous savez
pourquoi donc dites moi vous savez
pourquoi
j'attendis bouissou le maire de ivre il
a succédé au maire de ville d'ivry qui
est décédé en cours de mandat
oui c'est un jeune maire dynamique
entièrement disponibilité premier
adjoint il est devenu maire il est très
connu dans la ville et vous voyez ce que
vous avez cités ils sont dix lui s'il
gagne il ya droit pendant plusieurs
mandats et donc qu'ils sont en train
fait un puzzle
ils sont en train de lui tailler une
croupière parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
qu'il gagne eh bien vous savez il va
gagner
vous avez gagnez pas vous allez à la
confiance de sa ville et de ses
électeurs vous savez il n'est pas là bas
le maire communiste il est le maire de
tous les habitants où il en est la
démonstration une autre petite question
à strasbourg vous êtes là pour le coup
avec les écologistes et il ya une
candidate qui est voilée sur la liste
dans laquelle vous participez nous a
prouvé à strasbourg alors elle vous met
en place et la gestion d ailleurs à
julien bayou qui sont des appareils
alors là je ferai un vous condamnez vous
vous retirez c'est pas ma tasse de thé
c'est pas votre tasse de thé vous vous
diriez un peu comme le ministre de
l'éducation nationale s'est pas
souhaitable oui je pense que il ya des
règles qui sont imposés aux
fonctionnaires séoul a vieilli seriez
pas venu ici non
ac strasbourg il aurait fallu en
discuter avec les camarades moi cette
personne par exemple elle peut enfin je
vais vous dire franchement je me
préoccupe plus de ce qu'elles ont dans
la tête que sur la tête
vous connaissez peut-être essayer de
vous échapper non vous connaissez mal à
ma première réaction laquelle la tuque
ravens athènes
oui vous connaissez sur elle serait une
formidable élus elle porte le foulard
oui mais s'il faut de reptiles nous
servir sa bière ferrand mais c'est
l'inférence en l2 pourrait tout sa femme
elle pourrait tout à fait être non c'est
pas brillant ballon alors dont je vous
invite à les bandits donc j'aimerais
bien connaître le foulard
vous allez donc comme quoi oui mais
comme quoi comme quoi ce n'est pas la
question une femme voilée d'un comprenez
bien puisque la cia je ne vous la
connaissez et ça ne vous choquerait pas
qu'elle soit élue donc c'est plus il
faut mieux se préoccuper des combats
qu'elle porte et qui doivent être des
combats républicains
oui parce que si c'est pour autre chose
bien recel alors non je ne cautionne pas
bien au sel
le parti communiste c'est quoi pour lui
ces élections municipales puisque vous
allez vous mesurer avec le nombre
d'élues va voir la france insoumise avec
les écologistes avec le parti socialiste
vous étiez un parti qui était très ancré
sur le territoire n'ont parlé pendant
parfait est ce que vous allez pas peur
un peu d'être et bien par exemple
derrière la france à soutenir les
économies sont alors d'abord on n'est
pas en compétition mais c'est pas comme
ça du tout on ne mesure pas combien on
en aura à la fin c'est à peu près du
corps sciemment pouy financièrement mais
pas que oui parce que les élus
communistes eux reverse une part de
leurs émoluments les autres ce sont les
seuls élus en france qui quand ils sont
élus ne s'enrichissent pas et qu'ils
reversent une part de leurs émoluments
bien pour nous cette élection municipale
est une élection majeure parce que nous
sommes implantés dans de très nombreuses
villes
il y a cinq cent 500 650 est une commune
avec un maire communiste et le double
triple de communes où nous sommes
présents ou dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition
nous faisons ça avec coeur de manière
dévoué intègres et honnêtes les élus
communistes ont reconnu là où ils sont
élus comme étant des gens vous êtes
confiant
donc oui je suis confiant oui je suis
confiant parce que là où nous sommes
élus nous sommes toujours reconnus pour
notre travail et ensuite nous avons des
programmes où nous avons nous mettons en
avant le besoin de proximité de services
publics de défis écologiques les
transports gratuits par exemple c'est
quelque chose qui montrait très fort et
que nous vendons pour 1
des raisons évidemment idéologique pour
des raisons financières et pour des
raisons sénatoriales puisque comme
chacun sait les maires et leurs adjoints
sont appelés à voter pour les élections
sénatoriales vous avez 16 sénateurs
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas peur
un groupe sénatorial ses 10 est-ce que
vous avez pas peur si jamais ça se
présente mal tout ça que bien votre
groupe fond comme neige au soleil au
sénat non non ça fait ça fait plus enfin
vous demander si j'ai peur libre avec la
peur au ventre
on est des militants on mène un combat
dans une ville c'est un combat local
pour les enjeux locaux et nous ferons
tout vous savez quand nous avons des
sénateurs justement notre force et j'ai
mené la dernière campagne des
sénatoriales dans le nord nous faisons
beaucoup plus de voix que le nombre
d'élus communistes que nous avons on le
savait ça à chaque fois nous arrivons à
faire au moins un tiers de plus de voix
ça veut dire qu'il ya des élus
républicains ou sans étiquette qui
votent pour nous car nous sommes des
bombers des communes de france de la
ruralité comme guy métropole hay est ce
que vous serez présent en 2022 2001 2 si
je suis pas atteint par l'épidémie jeu
pour que vous aurez vous que je ne sois
pas présent à l'essentiel est ce que
c'est une élection
est ce que ça ferait bien l'idée
communiste cette question elle sera
débattue par les communistes et décider
de notre choix
quand le moment là le centralisme
dégrade rapidement nous sommes à parti
démocratique chez nous ça s'exerce il y
aura pas de 49,3 pour imposer la
décision ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que dans ce pays pour redonner de
l'espoir à gauche pour retrouver une
gauche authentique et sincère il faut un
parti communiste fort et influents et ça
c'est le combat que je veux mener
tradition se mènera sur plusieurs années
de tradition c'est le secrétaire
national du parti communiste avant
c'était le secrétaire général qui va au
combat et on verra ça ça se décidera
ensemble et en temps voulu pour
l'instant vous n'êtes pas candidat et
pour l'instant je me bats pour que le
parti communiste français soit retrouve
ses couleurs et défendre ses idées et
notamment chaque élection merci merci et
assez bougon prochain gala
votre audition publique fabien roussel
merci d'avoir accepté de débattre et de
répondre à toutes les questions qui se
sont posées là n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
figaro live ainsi que sur les comptes
twitter de lcp public sénat et auditions
publiques revient en direct lundi
prochain 19 heures
[Musique]